connaissez-vous les missions du conseil
départemental le conseil départemental
c'est tout d'abord une assemblée de 34
conseillers départementaux qui élisent
parmi eux un président ou une présidente
il y à un binôme hommes femmes élues
pour chacun des 17 cantons ses 34
conseillers départementaux des sites des
grandes politiques publiques et des
services organisés pour les haut-rhinois
pour cela il s'appuie sur une
administration départementale de 2400
agents vous ne le savez pas toujours
mais ses élus et ses 2400 agents
départementaux travail à votre service
tous les jours un peu comme des super
héros au quotidien
la principale mission du conseil
départemental c'est le social ces agents
aide les personnes à surmonter leurs
difficultés
veillez à la bonne santé des jeunes
mamans et des tout-petits soutenir les
familles fragilisées protéger les
enfants en danger
verser le rsa mais surtout et des six
bénéficiaires à se réinsérer et à
retrouver un emploi
permettre aux personnes handicapées de
vivre le mieux possible
aider les personnes âgées à vivre à leur
domicile
mais ainsi financer les maisons de
retraite
le conseil départemental déploie aussi
ses agents dans les collèges
construction rénovation entretien
et oui c'est à eux qu'on les doigts et
le repas de la cantine
encore des agents pour les roots aussi
il y a les agents que l'on voit ils
entretiennent ils des neiges est ce que
l'on voit pas qui travaille sur de
nouveaux projets aménagements de
carrefours déviation en notre objectif
du conseil départemental et que le sport
et la culture soit accessible à tous
dans les villes et les villages
c'est le rôle par exemple des médias bus
le conseil départemental animaux si les
réseau des médiathèques soutient les
écoles de musique ainsi que de
nombreuses associations les agents
dédiés à l'environnement eux gèrent et
protège des rivières mais ce n'est qu'un
exemple parmi d'autres il s'occupe aussi
des d'énergie durable de la protection
des espaces naturels de l'aide aux
agriculteurs et aux producteurs locaux
le conseil départemental et ses agents
sont souvent aux côtés des communes et
intercommunalités pour les aider à
développer leurs projets voilà vous en
savez un peu plus sur les élus et les
agents super héros
moins visible du conseil départemental
ils agissent au quotidien pour vous pour
votre bien-être et votre cadre de vie
vous avez envie d'en savoir plus
consultez notre site internet au tir et
un point fr